joining us now with much more South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham is with
us he was of course leading these
hearings with William Bar today senator
good to see him Thank You Sean thank you
very much your thoughts on the hearings
does just start there and we'll build
bar do the things that Jeff sessions did
not do and that is the deep state that's
Hillary Clinton and all the people we
mentioned earlier yeah I believe so I've
seen no evidence collusion between the
Trump campaign and Russians but I've
seen a lot of corruption in the
Department of Justice and the FBI have
every confidence that mr. Barr is going
to ask questions how can you certify to
the FISA Court on four separate
occasions that you have enough evidence
to get a warrant against American
citizen when the evidence the dossier is
unverified to this day I think he's
going to look long and hard at the
Department of Justice and the FBI and
the way they conducted the Clinton
investigation and the way this way they
started up the Muller investigation
here's long story short mr. Barr
believes that politicians should not
interfere in criminal investigations but
he also believes that criminal
investigators should not be out to get
politicians and they were out to get
Trump there are a lot of forces working
against them but for example I know if I
deleted emails as emotionally yeah I go
to jail are you confident he will do
that because every other American I
guess if you're being investigated and
subpoenaed your emails you can erase
them is that what Hillary has taught us
because I don't believe I believe that's
breaking the law well here's what I hope
I hope you go back and look at why she
got away with this they were out to get
Trump they say those themselves and
they're out to help her so I want him to
do more than mr. Horowitz did explain to
the country how it got so bad on him to
tell us what happened what the FISA
warrant application process how could it
get so off-base if there was a
counterintelligence investigation of the
president United States I want him to
tell us how it started who started it I
want him to clean up this mess I'm not
expecting him to throw Muller over but
Amex
him to clean up the mess at the
Department of Justice and FBI and I
think the president picked the right guy
to do it
I think there was we now know for a fact
that Russian lies were used to purposely
rig and also an investigation into
Hillary was rigged paid for by there was
a Kramer candidate over another
candidate yeah all right and then an
insurance policy and a leak strategy if
that failed all right let me let me move
to the issue of immigration I think the
president I don't really care which way
he gets it because wives are at stake we
have 90 percent of heroin coming into
this country from our southern border
human trafficking etc president decides
a national emergencies needed that's
fine you've been talking to people and
you have a different approach what is it
well I think he needs to build this wall
because we need the wall I think
Democrats are being hypocritical because
they all voted for more wall funding
that the president's asking for so
there's two ways to build a wall Shaun
do it by yourself through executive
action which is the last resort but
maybe necessary the other option is to
get a legislative solution Nancy Pelosi
has said I'll give you $1 for the wall
and that's it I believe they're
Democrats in the Senate that would work
with the President to fund the wall
adequately meet his priorities if he
would do other things so mr. president
if Democrats come to you in the Senate
and say that we would like to work with
you for a few weeks to see if we can
solve this problem give them that give
them a chance and if they don't deliver
do it by yourself you think that you
could convince their those Democrats
exist in the south well well they got it
they got to come out of the shadows and
say we're willing to work with you mr.
president of to meet your priorities and
we want some things too but we reject
Nancy Pelosi's idea that you only get a
dollar for the wall if there are
Democrats willing to come forward to
work with you mr. president for a few
weeks to see if we can solve this take
them up on it and if you don't get a
using that'll habitat so you're gonna
have what five of 10 Republicans five
ten Democrats that say give us a chance
to do our job open the government and
then if it we don't get it done in three
weeks you should declare the national
emergency and use Pentagon
funds or other resources mr. president
if you're watching this show I think
there's some Democrats that would work
with you
that that we could get a deal with in
the Senate by the way no amnesty is
involved in us in my view for five
billion dollars you don't get a pathway
to citizenship let's keep it simple
the bridge Act work permits no
citizenship if Democrats in the Senate
will work with you give them a chance a
couple of weeks if it doesn't work do it
yourself but give it one last year first
question is going to be $1 Nancy okay
maybe I will work with you I wouldn't
doubt they were embarrassed by Nancy
Pelosi and probably worried about her
extremism the first question is people
what is Nancy gonna say I'm dying to
hear what they will say get them in a
room and ask them that question see
where we go all right senator Graham
good to see you